hi I'm Bryce vine and this is a song
called take me home
Oh
well I've got a four-song EP coming out
near the end of the summer and they all
are a little kind of different piece of
me so I'm really excited to put that out
I think a lot more people are gonna
respond to the EP they did the video
because it's the first thing that they
could see and this is going to give
people a chance to see a bunch of
different kind of personalities that I
have I think it's gonna be solid I have
two music videos coming up in the next
couple months one for my song where the
wild things are that is gonna be on the
EP and another first song best days that
I think people will really enjoy it was
actually the first song that we ever
wrote and the video is gonna be
something real crazy for that one so
stay tuned and yeah the EP comes out in
a month I'll obviously be tweeting about
it follow me on Twitter Bryce vine for
everything Twitter Instagram Facebook
and I'll be letting everybody know very
shortly the next things that are coming
up